so what about all this beastly
partisanship in the newspapers do you
think it has been worse or is that even
a bad thing I think it's been
transparent so that's the important
thing I think you've no doubt where some
of the newspapers you know the mail and
the Sun stay where they stand I mean
what we've tried to do is to introduce
arguments and then that leads to a
endorsement in the end we said that we
thought the Tories would be best for the
London economy give the best deal to
London doesn't mean that we're saying
readers will all you know pay absolute
attention to this and actually they're
all voters they like as we see the eye
you said you decide we went down this
approach I mean you know this election
is not going to be decided by the
union's by rich donors by newspaper
proprietors or even journalists it's
going to be decided by the public your
viewers our readers and so we decided to
be neutral and that was to present all
of the arguments for all of the
different parties and to give all of the
leaders a chance to write in our paper
this morning with their final pitch to
voters learn about i suppose what
support views what's good for your
readership which is the financial
business community around the world you
dig obviously the crucial point for us
was to assess the economic record of the
coalition to look at ed Miliband's
policy proposals largely turning on the
economy and also try and set this in
some kind of international context and I
should stress despite what you
occasionally read in the twittersphere
or elsewhere that this was very much a
decision taken collectively it too long
discussions and then a conclusion now
you have got as you say this
international readership what interested
me was your chief economic writer today
actually says you can't really trust any
of them on the
we know that we've done particularly
well well we have a very broad church
that the financial times as you probably
know the commentators felt that they
were lent more towards or the economics
and political commentators meant more
towards a plan B whereas the editorial
line was somewhat more supportive of the
coalition I mean as it turns out we got
a plan a B with quite a flip of flexible
fiscal policy but but I mean overall I
think for the Financial Times the most
important thing is to present the facts
to do proper authority of analysis and
yes we did in the end endorse a
conservative-led coalition but with with
a lot of conditions and some questions
so times you've obviously got London
readership with the units and in many
ways a lot of people throughout this
campaign said well London you know it's
different from everywhere else people
for hey differently they're rich they're
more liberal all the rest you think
that's fair don't think it affects okay
what people don't understand is and it
is something yet millibars picked up on
it the inequality in London that it's
not that actually everyone sits bathing
in champaign you know the ground to the
campaign's we've done on the standard
and have focused on on scream to the
poverty is your poll so showed that
labor may well be this made where they
get some of their keys maybe yeah and I
think partly that the narrative has
worked for them that somehow the Tories
are for the rich that has been quite
successful and for them and you know it
not necessarily true but it's a it's
work for them as a narrative alright
younger readers particularly
as appeals to them has adverse of a
quick read that it can be where do you
think they're heading I think more
towards labor and the Greens than others
but that's not you know that's not
guarantee labour can't take it for
granted I think the sort of newspaper
endorsements we're looking at here as
seen increasingly as an anachronism to
younger readers you know because they're
getting a lot of their news online and I
should also add I think there's a huge
difference between the sort of
endorsements that we've seen in the FT
and an evening standard and to some of
the other papers which seem to
collectively lost their senses and the
hysterical front pages we saw this
morning and you think you know where I'm
referred to but I think you're looking
at massive massive expansion of greens
among young readers you know we've
really seen that a huge huge membership
boost in our university students and as
far as the campaign is concerned some
people said it's boring people aren't
interested principled leaders today
saying this is the most important
decision you're making your principal
life huge decision I mean our take on it
as being yes we think our leaders have
been pretty cowardly pretty lily-livered
they've been hiding away from the public
you know they've been doing sort of
tours of Hedgehog some trees and
suburban industrial estates where
there's no one there that said though
this is a massive decision you know the
stakes are really high not only the
economic prosperity we're talking about
but also the future of the Union
Britain's place in Europe you know these
are some really fundamental decisions
that are going to be taken in the next
two years well is there another way to
campaign because it has been pretty
place safe and leave it to the handlers
this campaign isn't it what was
certainly a way of campaigning that
connects it better with ordinary voters
i mean the the number of promises that
have been made both by the conservatives
and labour and and everyone it's just
not credible and that's what martin wolf
was describing the housing policy is
utterly crazy in terms of stoking a
housing bubble i think that it's stretch
it's really struck me how the coalition
particularly the conservatives have
failed to make a solid case of voters
that actually look two million jobs have
been created more than two million jobs
during the lifetime of this coalition
tough decisions were made and yet this
has been lost in a sea of aggressive neg
campaigning which according to the polls
has had no effect whatsoever for example
if you look at the pledge for a
referendum the the go tough on
immigration has this dented you Kip not
according to the polls it's really quite
and and on also the attacks on eight
million citizens are like you know a lot
of people from abroad looking on say if
you look at the way the British economy
is before me that meant the Tories ought
to be miles ahead one yes miss to people
outside I just don't know nothing has
moved this entire campaign has been for
nothing sexy there's no effect at all
the reassuring thing I suppose is that
it has shown you can't ride the British
electric I think simply taking no Nate
economy has improved to be a drunk it's
been a campaign for from bunkers
obviously i think the Conservatives have
a problem where they fail to connect
with large parts of public and i think
that's a communications difficulty as
well I think there's huge parts of the
UK that are still not feeling that
economic growth they're still not
feeling a recovery and maybe it is round
the corner but people can't feel it
they're not going to be convinced into
believing it's happening ok am
prediction time where do you think we're
going to be this time or friday
conservatives largest party but no
majority and i probably agree this is
not what you'd expect to hear from an
editor that I really don't know I'm
gonna wait the feel the vote well I ball
I want to ask you if it is conservative
largest party but no majority who do
things better end up foreign minister oh
no no I give up night I just think it's
very important if it there really enough
slightly underreported angle is just how
well will the Liberal Democrats do
because if they do better than expected
if they get in the 30s this could have a
really disciple they could hold the
balance exactly I was a lot of time take
what are you hate Nick I think Cameron
might just at the edge bird again I'd be
cautious about okay we'll keep your eyes
on the liver Democrats thank you all
very much indeed